quatre individus interpellés hier soir
sur l'autoroute en direction de
l'espagne
ils sont soupçonnés d'être impliqués
dans la mort du brigadier éric masson
tué mercredi lors d'une intervention
contre un point de trafic de drogue
cette nuit à paris des dizaines de
policiers se sont réunis devant le
commissariat du 8e arrondissement pour
rendre hommage à leur collègue décédé
après minute de silence ils ont chanté
la marseillaise avant d'allumer des
bougies et en service aujourd'hui je
n'ai pas pu me rendre à avignon
donc c'était le moyen de rendre hommage
à notre collègue je le comparerais pas
viry-châtillon parce que c'est pas les
mêmes événements c'est pas la même chose
mais mais en fait on a ça a réveillé une
certaine douleur la fragilité de notre
métier le fait que à tout moment dans
n'importe quelle intervention de police
on peut on peut mourir vont peut être
tué
c'est aussi on veut tuer aussi
froidement et c'est ça qui avec je pense
réveiller toute l'émotion de la police
nationale on est on est une cocotte
minute qui il voue depuis maintenant
trop longtemps
là c'est le temps des hommages
on pleure notre collègue mais c'est vrai
qu'on sent une tension est palpable de
pire en pire